c'è sempre quest'uomo che chi sorprese
ne ha infinite che è praticamente per il
mio compleanno ha deciso di regalarmi
una qualche cosa che ancora non ho
capito comunque il mio compleanno nella
tipo un mese e mezzo fa però noi ci
facciamo i regali il ritardo sempre mi
vuole portare da qualche parte però non
ho capito io giuro non so dove stiamo
andando
però mi ha detto puoi bloccare perché
carino se però chi ci vediamo dopo non
so dove stiamo andando però bella vagava
siccome non so dove stiamo andando
pensavo fossimo già arrivati quasi più o
meno no ma visto che siamo tipo da
mezz'ora in macchina poi mi ha indicato
il navigatore che dice che arriviamo tra
un'ora e mezza tra 19 dove stiamo
andando fra in un posto bellissima in
tibet visto che non c'è scritta la
destinazione sul navigatore ho studiato
attentamente il telefono ho capito dove
stiamo andando
non in giappone come si dice arriviamo
in giapponese
[Musica]
ma se sto pezzo e non capisco cosa fare
quando non finisce qui parlo un po a
caso faccio finta di capaci ma non lo so
che bel passatempo
[Musica]
va bene basta bellissimo abbiamo
scoperto dopo un'ora e mezza dove stiamo
andando e the a verona dopo un'ora e
mezzo abbiamo capito dove sta
se ho capito fortunatamente lo sa sono
siamo nella cacca fino a verona ci siamo
pronti dove ci saranno tantissimi colori
in un asilo
avrei dovuto immaginarlo alla banca
popolare puoi farmi versare i cessi fare
come in casa di carta ma come siamo
finiti a verona in una giornata dove
pensavo di finire a casalpusterlengo sai
come si chiama questo ponte ed io sì che
lo so come ponte levatoio assieme a
gabry dai fra prima grazie le views
grazie a me stai facendo fare il turista
ragazzi siamo a verona in questo blog è
oggi farò alberto angela che vi spiega
come vengono su con mai creato minecraft
devolo gare no il blogger quelli che a
milioni di iscritti sigla organo da soli
e sto pagando software si nicchia ma che
altro
davvero e vabbè dai portafortuna
vediamo gino e teresa perfetta prima
cosa colletti allora buongiorno insomma
ma è bella vero non c'ero mai stato
perché mi porta in questi posti
romantici avrà un secondo fine lorenzo
secondo me se no non ci credo sono
andato a noi le corriere secondo me
quell'uomo un secondo fine mi ha portato
quadro che si portano le ragazze di
solito si come lorenzo è stato così smi
amato da portare un pennarello vincente
gli gen tissimo esatto adesso scriveremo
qui su questo punto quali sapete dove
scriviamolo invece scritto lo re e io
scrivo loro e due
così almeno sapete che chi viene qua c'è
la nostra scritta loro due
fatevi una foto e mandate mela nelle i
miei directed instagram
se trovate questa scritta quando nel
direct agate raga che una hit al
telefoto guardate dove siamo così capite
in quella scritta nostra siamo qua ok
verità ponte e hanno capito il ponte
hanno capito hanno capito non sono scemi
hanno capito ma che alla fine ho
scoperto qual era il mio regalo lorenzo
sono lo vedete è lì che sexy man e siamo
signori e signori
al colosseo non so se vi ricordate la
gaffe che ho fatto durante quell
episodio di come che si chiamava trova
no vabbè quello dove indovinare il posto
dove l'ho scambiato l'arena di verona
per il colosseo solo perché sono una
persona acculturata della indovino anche
se c'è poca qualità perché sono una
persona troppo acculturata io qui
ah già e siamo all'arena di verona in
realtà c'è il concerto di jovanotti
siccome lorenzo mi ha portato qua io
sono lorenzo quindi lorenzo ha portato
lorenzo a vedere lorenzo perché anche
jovanotti si chiama lorenzo è tutto un
inciucio tra lorenzi prova niente era
che abbiamo appena beccato giovane aveva
fatto due chiacchiere questa è la foto
sono proprio contento di essere quasi
mentre adesso la renault che grossa e
quando qualcuno cerca di far partire la
ora ma non ci riesce però apprezziamo il
tentativo
attivo poco riuscito mi spiace un sacco
[Applauso]
detto fatto
famiglia l'uomo l'uomo del mondo numero
uno dategli i miei scritti
abbiamo sbagliato concerto fra aderente
conterà cali che abbiamo sbagliato
davide jovanotti come questa è una cosa
che non mi son rimasti in vita mia
gta sullo sfondo del mare 130
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma galan sito è del generalissimo cosa e
non ha bevuto niente fumo e rido l'altro
alfabeto tra lira ira l'ira ragazzi
iniziato a fare un freddo cane cane
stiamo aveva un che abbiamo finito stato
molto divertente
ci siamo stati troppi lorenzi in questa
in questa giornata comunque stato molto
molto figo si contento di questo
concerto sono mega contento e non mi
stanco mai di vederlo va bene adesso
andiamo ad albano energia buona
[Musica]
al quarto alfabeto